foreign
the AI hoax is not really what I'm going
to be speaking about what I want to
explain today is that even if it's a
complete mistake to expect biological
intelligence to be replicable in
silicon-based machines
the opposite could still seem inevitable
to people
for a complicated set of reasons to do
with founding philosophical assumptions
of Science and Technology in the history
of industrialization AI could look
inevitable even though it's impossible
perfect
so to begin to get everything clear what
are we actually talking about today
the term AI is used to refer to many
different kinds of Technology
both actual ones and science fictional
ones
my focus is on the kind of AI that
aspires to replicate the all-round
intelligence of human beings or more
modestly of animals who cognitive skills
we're quite familiar with like a dog or
a cat
this is what's normally known as
artificial general intelligence or AGI
what do we mean by artificial
the double meaning of this word was
something that was noticed by one of the
founders of AI research the American
cognitive scientists and Economist
Herbert Simon
so I'll give you some of his words on a
slide
so as he writes here he looked at his
dictionary
and saw that it defines artificial as
produced by Art rather than by Nature
not genuine or natural I should say
affected not pertaining to the essence
of the matter
and you can see there that there are
these synonyms affected factitious
manufactured sham
it's Furious chomped up
and then what would be the opposite of
artificial is actual genuine honest real
truthful
so he's saying that with this double
meaning of artificial you see that
there's this ambivalent feeling that
people have towards their own products
but what he wants it to mean by
artificial in the term AI is just this
neutral thing that it's man-made as
opposed to Natural
but to lay my cards on the table
I think that the negative meaning that
Herbert Simon dislikes
gives you the right way to think about
the artificial in current Ai and this is
based on deep learning in artificial
neural networks so I've put on the
slides here just a schematic of one of
these deep learning architectures that
you might have heard about which would
be behind say face recognition
technology or object recognition and
some like famous examples of this that
have been in the news would be
Technologies like gpt3 the language
processing AI or alphago the one that
deepminds produced a few years ago and
beat old Grandmaster at the game of Go
so it's a kind of it's often talked
about as like a simulation of a brain
Network because you see all of these
little nodes here they're very schematic
idealized
um computer models of what people maybe
60 years ago thought was going on in
actual neurons in your brain but all
neuroscientists know that the brain
itself operates in a way which is quite
different from what's simulated in a
model like this so there is this
um kind of
yeah there's this and of ambivalence
within the community of thinking of
these as in some sense artificial brains
but in other ways recognizing that
they're really not brain-like at all and
neuroscientists themselves are
interested in the capability of these
machines as maybe giving you insight
into how the brain actually works
but I don't think they work in any way
like the actual brain for reasons that
I'll talk about
but yeah basically what I think is going
on with these Creations like alphago is
that they have something more like a
nurse at intelligence that they're a
very impressive imitation but not the
real thing
I actually think that there's more
genuine intelligence in a worm
than in gpt3
so here's an interesting example of a
use of gpt3 this language massive AI
Network which is a language generator
so what it does is that you can train it
on text that humans produced and it kind
of learns the stylistic patterns of the
text
so what the what's going on here is that
um The Human Side of this project train
gpt3 on the stylistic works of a
particular poet
and after dpt3 had been exposed to lots
and lots of these poems it was able to
generate its own text in the style so
this is actually a poem created by dpt3
and it's kind of poetic and this is an
image generated by another artificial
neural network which is kind of trained
to do sketch-like work
what's really important about this
project though is that
The Human Side of the working the work
the person that had actually instigated
this project had to edit what dpt3
created so it's not like dpt3 by itself
could just generate poems that sounded
good the human had to like take Snippets
and lines and sort of put them together
in a way that was more Artful than that
so I think that's something that often
gets forgotten when people talk about
like the capabilities of these machines
so anyway I think the worm is more
intelligent than this poetry creating
machine
so in board Strokes the reason for my
thinking that current Technologies are
not a step along the way to AGI and that
human-like intelligence will never be
replicated in digital Computing machines
is that I think that there is a much
deeper connection between intelligence
and aliveness than AI proponents realize
this prompts us to ask what is
intelligence
sorry but now this is a question which
is much too big an issue to be dealt
with in just one slide
but anyway let me just contrast some
different ways to think about
intelligence
so this first way that I've put up here
just says that well something which
could be a machine is intelligent just
when it has some of the cognitive
capacities which are distinctive of
human beings or some other animals and
this is a way of thinking about of
intelligence that has really dominated
the field of artificial intelligence so
when Engineers like set up a benchmark
saying that when a machine can play
chess or when a machine can play go it
is in some way intelligent when it can
do facial object facial recognition or
object recognition that's saying well
when you can get the machine to do
something clever that a personal animal
can do then it's on the way to being
completely clever or like an animal or a
person
but this other way of thinking about
what intelligence is is saying that
there's this pervasive property of
living beings which you can't disconnect
from our idea of intelligence
so on the second view the point is that
in order just to stay alive an organism
even a bacterium even a single-celled
organism needs sensitivity to its
environments behavioral adaptivity some
kind of ability to learn
or to utilize past experience and this
is saying that plants microbes fungi
with all their signaling as well as
animals are in some sense intelligent
so at least at some base level there is
intelligence everywhere amongst living
things
this suggests that live all living
things have some form of intelligence
but not that only living things can be
intelligent
so it's compatible with this view it
seems that there could be artificial
non-biological versions of these
capabilities
but here's why I think the pervasiveness
of biological intelligence is relevant
to the argument about AI
so the brain is an organ in a living
body the nervous system is made up of
living cells if these cells are already
like core cells intelligent in some
sense let's call them protocognitive
this must be relevant to how it is that
animals with brains and nervous systems
have all the capacities that we classify
as obviously intelligent
for example
a living cell is an inherently adaptive
entity
it's learning is a fundamental component
of the intelligence of humans and other
animals
learning is explained by neuroscientists
in terms of brain plasticity
the constant restructuring that occurs
amongst brain cells at many scales
throughout life
it must be that plant brain plasticity
and therefore learning has the peculiar
properties that it has because of the
inherent adaptiveness of all living
cells
it's interesting that artificial neural
networks underlying current AI in a very
simplified form one kind of plasticity
that goes on in the brain
but the process with which it's supposed
to mimic learning its training algorithm
is very unlike anything in the brain
this is probably because the neural
network is running on Computing Hardware
that has none of those proto-cognitive
properties of living tissue
it gives us as learning without the
sensitivity and multi-scale adaptiveness
of the original
but there's an argument that's often
brought up here
when people like me who are skeptical
about the prospects for AI make this
observation that the only unquestionably
intelligent things are living beings
so they'll say that well I'm in the
situation now of someone at the turn of
the previous Century who looked around
and saw that the only flying things were
living things they were birds and
insects and said well it's impossible
for a machine to have a fly and of
course they were proven wrong not soon
after that
so the idea that people who were pro-ai
come out with here is to say though
there's no inherent connection between
being able to fly and being alive that
there is some same laws of aerodynamics
which go across whether you're a living
thing or a machine and they'll say by
the same turn there are the same laws of
cognition the same laws of intelligence
which hold whether you're a machine an
artificial thing a non-living thing or
whether you're a biological creature
so they'll say of course you know
cognitive science can study intelligence
whether it's in a machine or in an
animal
but I think the problem with this
argument is that there's a big
difference with what I'm claiming about
the essential connection between life
and intelligence
most living things can't actually fly
flight is not essential to being alive
whereas my suspicion is that some form
of intelligence proto-cognition really
is necessary and essential for life
which means that to properly understand
intelligence
you you need to root it in its
biological context
and this is what makes me skeptical that
you could have genuine intelligence and
not fake artificial intelligence in
anything other than a living system
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas